foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to once
again be discussing plot holes from the
Harry Potter movies why did Harry lie to
Hedwig And what mysterious horcrux
should have been destroyed we'll answer
those questions and more when we take a
look at some big and small plot holes
from the Chamber of Secrets film 8. you
don't need glasses with Polyjuice
Polyjuice Potion is one of those classic
concoctions that seems to open itself up
to a ton of tiny plot holes and when we
look at how the magical potion was used
in the Chamber of Secrets this trend
continues at one point Harry and Ron
chugged down a draft of Polyjuice and
transformed into copies of crab and
Goyle but there's a small inconsistency
with the whole scene when Eric
transforms he forgets to take off his
glasses which doesn't really make sense
since it's been long established that
eyesight is one of the traits that
transforms after you consume poly juice
potion and then Harry should have
immediately noticed that he didn't need
his glasses unless Malfoy's like he's
also suffered from poor vision and
simply never wore glasses because they
were too Vain and didn't want to be
teased by Draco 7. Harry lied to Hedwig
long before Harry had any inkling the
two basilisk lived in the dungeons of
Hogwarts he was busy suffering through
the summer months amongst the Muggles at
one point while sitting alongside Hedwig
the owls seemed to make a gesture
towards Harry almost as if she was
asking to be released from her cage so
she could enjoy a quick flight but Harry
didn't open the small door to her cage
instead he simply stated to Hedwig that
he wasn't allowed to use magic outside
of Hogwarts but if you think about it
why would Harry need to use magic in
order to open her cage all he needed was
a tiny key which was clearly visible
either Harry lied because he didn't want
to deal with taking his pet for a flight
or something else was a a foot 6. how
did nearly headless Nick recover
whenever a poor helpless victim stared
into the eyes of a basilisk they were
sure to die that's what made the massive
serpent such a terrifying beast but
during Harry's second year at Hogwarts
the students and creatures who were
struck by the basilisks gays were lucky
to avoid it directly they simply saw the
dark snake's eyes through a reflection
which spared them from Death instead
these victims were petrified and stuck
in a suspended state but besides these
fortunate living beings there was one
Undead Spirit who met the basilisk's
eyes straight on nearly headless Nick
since Nick was already dead the
basilisk's gays wasn't able to push him
further away from the living world
instead it seemed to petrify him as well
now those among the living who saw the
basilisks gays had a long difficult road
to recovery they managed to be cured
through the meticulous wish craft of
Madame Pomfrey in Hogwarts Hospital Wing
but those elixirs and remedies must not
have had much of an effect on ghosts so
how did Nick manage to recover from the
attack of one of the deadliest dark
creatures in the entire Wizarding World
I'm surprised it had any effect on him
in the first place 5. why did Dobby want
to save Harry Dobby's courage and the
stoutness of ourselves were among the
most endearing parts of the Chamber of
Secrets but have you ever wondered why
Dobby went through Such Great Lengths to
save Harry because if you think of all
the ways that a house self might expend
their energy helping a random second
year Hogwarts student isn't one of the
best ways although Dobby probably heard
of Harry Potter when he was
eavesdropping on draco's conversations
with his mother what would have made
Dobby so obsessed with the boy who lived
and how could Dobby have known that
Harry was going to be the target of the
creature within the Chamber of Secrets
even though the Malfoy's thought very
little of ourselves and Dobby particular
Lucius was a somewhat discreet wizard
he's not the type to openly discuss a
secret plot like the one that saw him
surreptitiously slip Tom Riddle's Diary
into Ginny Weasley's things how Dobby
knew about the chamber and why Dobby
decided to save Harry are two issues
that don't clearly have answers of
course there are a few different
explanations that might partially fill
this plot hole Dobby obviously knew that
the Death Eaters and their leader were
even worse than normal Wizards when it
came to the cam of house elves and if
Lord Voldemort successfully overthrew
the ministry of magic then Dobby's life
would be far worse off
perhaps that was enough for Dobby to
become obsessed with Harry and tried to
save him 4. gilderoy Lockhart doesn't
make any sense as much as I love Gilroy
Lockhart his very existence seems to
undermine the intelligence of the rest
of the Wizarding Community Harry Ron and
Hermione pretty easily determined that
Lockhart was a fraudster and I know I
know these three Hogwarts students
aren't exactly run-of-the-mill Wizards
and witches together they've achieved
Greater Heights than many adult magic
users in The Wizarding World but still
it's strange that these children exposed
Lockhart quicker than anyone else and to
make no mistake by the start of Harry
Potter's second school year gilderoy
Lockhart's act as the most courageous
wizard in Britain was still untarnished
after all besides Albus Dumbledore a few
Wizards even suspected that Lockhart's
achievements weren't his own and even
Dumbledore's perspective on the matter
wasn't fully explained until JK Rowling
and a separate piece explaining why the
wise old wizard would have wasted his
students time with such a worthless
Professor sure some like Severus Snape
had their doubts but it's pretty strange
that the rest of the Hogwarts faculty
didn't see right through Lockhart and
immediately request his dismissal from
the school perhaps they kept their mouth
shut out of respect for Dumbledore 3.
basilisk Venom and Harry's horcrux in
the depths of Hogwarts while fending off
the Basilisk in the Chamber of Secrets
Harry struggled to keep the serpent at
Bay and in the end when he struck a
killing blow on the snake Harry himself
received a mortal wound one of the dark
creatures fangs pierced Harry's skin and
injected him with the infamous basilisk
Venom from that moment only a few
minutes would pass until Harry Met
certain death of course Volks the
Phoenix who fought by Albus Dumbledore's
side time and time again intervened his
tears healed Harry's wounds before the
Venom brought him to the other side but
that opens up a few questions as we know
basilisk Venom is one of the only
materials capable of destroying
horcruxes in fact when Harry Ron and
Hermione scour the British Countryside
during the event of the Deathly Hallows
it's almost exclusively basilisk Venom
and the Venom Powers passed on to
gryffindor's sword that they use so
shouldn't the Venom have killed the bit
of Voldemort soul that had latched onto
Harry eventually JK Rowling was forced
to answer this question but that answer
only seemed to justify the horcrux's
continued existence on a technicality if
you're interested in a full explanation
I've done a video on it 2. broken ones
should work but Ron's doesn't throughout
the Chamber of Secrets Ron Weasley
starkly faces life at Hogwarts with a
broken wand unfortunately for the
youngest Weasley boy his wand had been
all but destroyed during his flight to
Hogwarts at the beginning of the
semester now Ron could have easily asked
his parents for a new one from
ollivander's shop but that would have
run the risk of a scolding and Ron was
already too traumatized to receive yet
another howler in the Great Hall in
front of all of his peers so Ron simply
suffered enduring failure after failure
as he struggled to fulfill the most
basic spells but Ron's experience with a
broken wand doesn't really compare well
to others Hagrid famously used a broken
wand after it was first shattered when
he was expelled from Hogwarts decades
prior yes it was encased in an umbrella
but it was still broken even though the
half giant suffered a few hiccups during
spellcasting he was still able to
achieve his desired results more or less
so that makes you wonder why was Ron's
wand so bad is this just a simple
pothole or was Ron's wand constructed of
inferior equipment or more likely was
Ron's own inexperience the reason why
his broken wand performed so poorly if
he had been a more experienced wizard
would he have cast better spells despite
the sad state of his wand 1. the
basilisk's size by the end of the
Chamber of Secrets the voices that Harry
Potter hears within the walls were
explained it was a basilisk and its
voice didn't come from the walls but
from the nooks crannies and pipes that
laid Beyond it but if you know anything
about indoor plumbing then you'd realize
that pipes are really really small
oftentimes even commercial grade
Plumbing is only a few inches in
diameter relatively normal non-exotic
snakes have been known to get stuck in
commercial plumbing and it's required
expensive plumbers to yank them out so
how could a basilisk which was larger
than many of the wingless dragons that
populated Hungary fit in such tiny
spaces well the simple answer is that it
couldn't even underground pipes might
not have fit the massive Beast so how
was it able to navigate around Hogwarts
and pop-up where students and cats these
six affected it as a Fantastical realm
even the sewage system within Hogwarts
was gigantic and dare I say Majestic
there were certainly places that a
basilisk could have faint but the
bathroom pipes don't seem like one and
there you have it eight plot holes from
the Harry Potter and the Chamber of
Secrets film what do you think which of
these potholes could you explain away
and which are just too clunky to solve
let me know in the comments below and if
you have any favorite plot holes of your
own make sure you share those as well
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live
[Music]
foreign